foreign
I'm super excited about this call this
is an update call
from the one and only Elizabeth from
Roanoke Virginia Elizabeth what are you
doing
what am I doing I'm I'm sober I'm good
I'm sobered nothing okay so you're
you're calling as with this with an
update seven months right was since we
since you and I talked
so take us all the way back to seven
months ago to now
uh well when I first called you at the
beginning of the year I was really on
the fence about quitting using marijuana
which at the time I was smoking every
day for almost a decade
and I even just re-listened to that
episode and I was really scared to stop
like that really I really like noticed
how scared I was to stop why were you
scared to stop shortly well I was scared
because I really felt like my feelings
would be overwhelming and I wouldn't be
able to tolerate just feeling kind of
like normal feelings
okay
um I don't I don't think I brought this
up last time can I just like right as
you just said that can I tell you
something that just popped into my head
yeah
you were you were in a civil war with
yourself
you were scared of you
100
.
wow
you were scared of you
I was like how you're gonna respond to
your husband how you can respond to that
boss how you can respond to that person
cut you off in traffic how are you going
to respond to those childhood trauma
things that you haven't dealt with you
were scared of you
yeah and so I guess for a decade we'd
helped you shut you up for a minute
right
yeah pretty much but I was running
using it so then I was really on the
fence because it wasn't really giving me
relief anymore I had a new set of
problems from using but then I had this
like scary idea of what it would be to
not be using okay so that's when I ended
up reaching out to you because I just
felt like so trapped by the decision yes
okay then what did I tell you to do
well I'm asking for a friend exactly
well I think what what really made a
difference for me was to remember that
the feeling will pass
and I think that that's something I
still carry with me
um because I had a tendency to feel like
the emotion I was feeling was everything
it was like my whole world I'm totally
overwhelming I couldn't cope with it and
forever it's it's everything and forever
yes
in this Jewish is like basically making
a commitment to just say like I'll try
it and that's when I ended up following
up with you after because I did try it
and it was going well
and so now fast forward is in seven
months and I'm I'm doing great you're
still sober seven months
yep wow okay it is really really rare to
not have
one or two or a couple of weeks of like
all right let's just you know
tell me about a time have you fallen off
at all
no not one time
nope wow and if I remember correctly
you're you're married and your husband
wasn't all in and then he kind of saw
how the lights were coming on for you
and tell me about where he is
but he took about two months off okay
now he's back to using okay he's been
really ambivalent about this the whole
time so I think he's still moving in the
direction of stopping completely but we
do have kind of different relationships
with substances and just our backgrounds
and things so
um yeah I think he's having some more
challenges but really really dedicated
to like kind of Follow The Path because
he sees how how great I've been
so this makes it even more amazing you
are somebody who is trying to
um
trying to quit eating sugar and you have
a partner who just brings gummy candies
and Twinkies into the house every day
that's that's extra hard extra actually
so you made a stone cold commitment
yeah and I was telling you when we
followed up last time it's really it was
around like my emotional health and my
mood and like I had been dealing with
depression on and off for decades and I
really wanted that to be resolved and
that's something that I really feel has
been the biggest benefit of stopping
using is that I haven't had one
depressive episode since I stopped what
do you attribute that to
uh well you know I have to say that
maybe taking away this this up and down
all the time really helped because like
when you're high you just want to be
lazy so then if you have anything to do
you're kind of pissed off you can't just
be lazy with a lot of extra just being
annoyed
um but then the next day you're more
tired and then that makes your day
harder so then you're more likely to be
stressed and then you want to use it's
just this kind of cycle that adds a
negative I found that it just was adding
this extra undercurrent of like
negativity
I I I mean
I think that's a brilliant Insight I
would also add to that one of the
cornerstones of healing from depression
is little wins
is teaching your body I can
and after you figure out I can that be
that morphs over time to I will
and that morphs over time to I am right
so I can not smoke this next five
minutes and then I can do the next five
minutes after that which then lets me
know I will quit all the way
which then goes to a new identity which
is I'm a person who takes care of their
body I don't do that
right
that's that's so true and I really feel
so strong now and there was even times
in the beginning where difficult
emotions and it was kind of like a
feeling of what do I do with my hands
I'm like I'm kind of awkward that I'm
doing so well
like aren't I supposed to have a
breakdown or something at this point and
so it's kind of uncomfortable to feel
balanced that I'll admit
so you have
it's it's amazing that you're saying
that because I was speaking with a
business uh owner yesterday I met with a
group of business owners
um uh it was a behind closed doors
meeting and one of them said
I started this practice
um
I started this practice
we were I've been running and gunning
and running and gunning this thing is
more successful than I ever could have
imagined
and I realized over time that I started
this thing out of I'll show you that I
can do this I can outrun my whatever I'm
going to earn my dad's blessing I'm
gonna keep running and write
and she said I don't know how
to run this thing in peacetime
I don't know how to say whoa we're here
we're making a jillion dollars our
business is good we're serving people
well
this is enough for now and she didn't
have a psychology for that or a set of
practices and that's exactly what you
just described like I know how to live
out of chaos and I know how to cover up
my emotions and I had to keep the other
half of Elizabeth quiet
I don't know how to just say that sucks
and then go about my day all right
that's a that's a new set of skills how
have you how have you leaned into that
have you practiced that new set of
skills because that's incredible
Elizabeth
thank you oh it's been tough because I
was using marijuana also to just relax I
felt like I was like on hyperdrive all
the time it was the only way I could
wind down and that it did just take
practice and a lot of self-talk to say
like it is okay to take a break or
acknowledge my boundaries because I
really wasn't acknowledging my
boundaries so now I'll be tired in the
middle of dishes and be like that's
enough for now and I'll just walk away
and before that would have stressed me
out I would have pushed myself so I got
irritated and I just I'm trying to to
prioritize the bigger things like
finishing the dishes in one standing is
not necessarily the most important thing
to me maybe it is that I need to go take
a break or respond to this phone call
step away
um do something that's more fulfilling I
guess because I would get just like
either hyperdrive and then smoke and
then become like a vegetable or uh oh
ground so I'm trying to just find that
balance
I I mean you you to say you're an
inspiration is the understatement of the
year you're incredible Elizabeth
and like stopping smoking weeds hard
after doing stopping anything right for
that you've been doing for a decade is
hard changing at that habit is hard
but what I have found over time is what
often sends people back
is trying to get through that awkward
stage of a new way of doing life
it's just like you I love the way you
just said that it's like I don't know
what to do with my hands like I'm just
standing here and you're looking at me
but it's you looking at you right and
that is that that awkwardness is so new
and so raw and so weird
dude I'm just gonna smoke right I'm just
gonna have another drink I'm you know
I'm gonna have cheeseburger that will
make the awkward go away
and you have I don't say powered through
it but you just made peace with it this
series this season's gonna be awkward
all right
kind of like it's winter so I'm gonna
wear a jacket okay I'm not gonna fight
the weather that's a waste of my energy
and time I'll just wear a coat
right exactly and I've been really
trying to work on not like labeling what
I feel
filed out of control so now I try to say
like I feel depressed right now and try
to caveat it like it's just right now
like I feel depressed right now what do
I need to do right now and I noticed
that shift in like the framing has been
so powerful too okay I'll even catch
myself be like I'm stressed out and I'm
like no I'm not I feel stressed right
now I love so it really helps shift my
mentality the great uh William Glasser
is a famous psychiatrist
um and I really like a lot of his a lot
of what he wrote he would not allow his
clients to use the words I'm depressed
or I'm anxious
he made them they had to say the words
I'm depressing or I I'm anxiety in or
I'm headaching I'm back aching
they had to take ownership of the things
their body was doing in order to keep
them safe or to protect them or to keep
them from feeling awkward Etc and that's
really similar to what you're doing you
don't say the words I'm depressed you're
like nope my body has a feeling right
now it's trying to send me a message
that uh it would rather not be taking
this phone call but we're gonna take
that phone call or I might be you take
the phone call right now because I don't
have to because I'm a grown-up right you
yeah exactly so great Elizabeth
incredible okay oh thank you go ahead go
ahead no
I will also remind you that this all
started because
um at the beginning of the year my
husband and I decided that we wanted to
try to have kids and I wanted to share
that I'm actually seven months pregnant
yeah
wow I love everything I've been like a
hormonal mess and I'm still feeling
great wow
yeah congratulations boy or girl thank
you good girl
I think John's still a good name for a
girl you can make that one yeah
johnette johnette yeah yes johnetta
johnetta
um Josh if that doesn't sound like a
never mind I was gonna make a
geographical joke and I won't do that um
yes John Adams sounds great I'm all in
for that I'll wear that shirt
um hey congratulations congrats congrats
congrats
um I appreciate it
know this I'm so proud of you
so proud thank you and I'm excited for
what comes next for you guys and okay I
always have to do this and I feel like
funrunner.com is that okay
sure
when you have this baby
oh man it's gonna be the most amazing
wonderful thing and there's gonna be a
flood of I'm not enough and shame and
Old School drama that comes back out
that you can't even it's gonna be
incredible it's like a fire two fires at
the same time
I want you to never forget I'm with you
every step of the way call me anytime
okay
all right thank you I'm so so so proud
of you and little johnette has won the
lottery with
um you as her mama it's gonna be so cool
man thank you so so much for calling
calling back in and checking in with us
ah you know day it's awesome seven
months after smoking out for a decade
every day
says I'm done I'm done
and I'm going to live with the awkward
I'm so proud of you